à peine nommé jean castex veut se mettre
au travail et le plus vite possible
il faut dire que la rentrée s'annonce
chargée et les chantiers qui l'attendent
sont de taille
premier objectif soutenir les
entreprises à travers un plan de relance
qui sera activé dès la rentrée car après
la crise sanitaire sauver l'économie
française est une priorité
l'objectif du gouvernement l'objectif de
l'état ses devoirs dans le cadre du plan
de relance de reconstruction et des
conséquences que l'on va tirer de cette
crise comment ne pas simplement agir sur
le court terme c'est déjà important pour
éviter un maximum de licenciement
comment on peut assurer les fondements
d'une relocalisation d'un maintien
durable des emplois industriels est
exposé à la concurrence dans notre pays
dans son bureau à matignon jean castex
devra s'atteler à l'épineux dossier de
la réforme des retraites un temps
écartée en raison de la crise du
coronavirus elle a été remise à l'ordre
du jour arrêt manuel macron il n'y aura
pas d'abandon de la réforme des
retraites
je suis ouvert à ce qu'elle soit
transformée mais le nouveau premier
ministre qui dit avoir l'ambition de
rassembler appel notamment au dialogue
avec les syndicats et affirme vouloir
trouver un compromis
la crise a aggravé fortement le déficit
de nos régimes de retraite
je souhaite reprendre le dialogue avec
les partenaires sociaux c'est
indispensable
arriverons-nous à régler ces dossiers à
court terme c'est mon souhait a minima
nous devrons nous fixer un nouvel agenda
social
je tends la main aux organisations
syndicales et patronales pour que nous
avancions ensemble
jean castex déclare également souhaité
que le ségur de la santé rende ses
conclusions dès la semaine prochaine un
dossier laissé inachevé par edouard
philippe alors qu'une enveloppe de 7
milliards d'euros pour revaloriser les
salaires des soignants se trouve sur la
table des décisions essentielles sont
sur la table
le soutien aux soignants et la
transformation de notre système de santé
dans le cadre du ségur que je conclurai
la semaine prochaine
le plan de relance doit être finalisée
après les gilles et jean est la
mobilisation contre la réforme des
retraites le chef du gouvernement veut
appuyer sa couvée
ans sur un nouveau pacte social dans la
perspective de faire émerger un nouveau
mode de concertation avant de donner des
solutions je souhaite que l'on en
discute avec la nation les partenaires
sociaux dans les territoires nous les
associeront le plus possible à la
recherche de solutions pour un nouveau
pacte social
autre gros chantier pour le premier
ministre et pas des moindres celui de
l'environnement
après la forte percée des écologistes
municipal jean castex va donc devoir se
mettre au vert pour répondre aux
attentes des français
agir pour l'environnement n'est pas une
option c'est une obligation
le précédent gouvernement avait initié
une méthode qui me paraît bonne mais
qu'il faut accélérer à partir des
territoires et des expériences qui
marche
nous allons lister avec les acteurs
locaux tout ce que l'on peut faire
immédiatement face à ses détracteurs qui
prédisent qu'il ne sera qu'un simple
exécutant d'un emmanuel macron
jupitérien jean castex a souligné dans
son entretien avec le jdd que le chef de
l'état ne voulait pas faire de lui un
subordonné voué aux tâches secondaires
quoi qu'il en soit le premier ministre
l'a confirmé son été sera studieux